I've learnt that anyone can be a god so  long as someone believes in them my  journey started with these two divorced  followers they looked up to me for  nurture and inspiration as they  developed their lives has sculpt and  mold every inch of this beautiful  landscape using only my touch as a grown  in power saw has their civilization  thrived I've watched my adoring  followers as they've lived and learned  and looked and enriched their lives as  they progressed through the edges of  humanity  however the path has not been without  difficulties at times it has been  challenging but I've had the power to  prevail  you  you